How can women who waited too long to have children find meaning in their lives
once they realized their mistake?
How can we cope with the regret?
Jesus?
That's a hard question.
Well,
you know,
there are other avenues to meaning,
right?
I mean,
that's,
that's the first thing to realize is that there are,
there's intimate relationship,
there's familial relationships that aren't in accordance with children.
There's other people that you can serve.
There are other children that you can serve.
So what you have to do,
because intimate relationships are so important,
and I'm including that close familial,
I'm not talking about sexual relationships.
I'm talking about very close social relationships.
The thing about having children,
if you're lucky,
is that you have a relationship there of a depth that you don't get anywhere
else with the possible exception of your parents and siblings and your partner.
But there's something about the child relationship that's even more fundamental
because the thing about having a child is that if you have any sense,
as soon as you have a child,
you are no longer the most important person,
right?
You're no longer the person that you have primary responsibility for.
It's now your child.
And that produces a psychological transformation and it produces a relationship
of a depth that can't be easily duplicated elsewhere.
But it's not like that's the only thing that there is to do in life.
You know,
there,
there are other relationships and I would say what you do is you foster them to
the degree that that's possible.
And maybe you could find other kids to serve.
You know,
there's always the possibility of volunteering for hospitals or,
or,
or working in places where children need service.
So that's a possibility as well.
And so you've,
you know,
there are,
there are a variety of sources of meaning in people's lives and they're,
they're not unlimited.
You know,
there's career,
there's education,
there's what you do that's meaningful,
meaningfully engages you outside of work.
There's your social relations,
your friends and so forth.
And so maybe you have five lakes lakes to stand on and you missed one cause he
didn't have kids.
Or maybe you miss too because kids are a big deal.
But that doesn't mean the rest of them aren't accessible to you.
And so you optimize your functioning along the dimensions that are left to you.
And then I would also say maybe you tried to forgive yourself a little bit.
You know,
like it's very difficult to go through life without
yeah.
Without regrets,
without making mistakes.
You know,
when you can't beat yourself to death for it because then everyone would beat
themselves to death all the time.
And so you think,
well that's,
that's I've,
I'm,
I'm too soon old and too late wise to use an old cliche and you think,
well that's the law of mankind.
We learn things too late often and that's too bad.
And you forgive yourself because you're stupid and you don't know what you're
doing and you're unwise just like everyone else.
And maybe you're somewhat capable of learning if you're careful.
And then you go out and you try to foster and do good in the world to the degree
that you can outside of the necessity of,
of children.
And maybe you have nephews,
nieces,
and you can lavish some attention on them and find your substitute where you
can.
But I would say to forgive yourself is a big part of that.
It's like people make mistakes,
mad big mistakes.
And the people that I've watched through life that have been successful,
it's not like they didn't make mistakes because everyone makes mistakes and they
do things they regret and they miss opportunities and it's a bloody catastrophe,
but they treat themselves with some degree of mercy along with the justice.
It's like,
yeah,
well I screwed up there and I'm going to try to learn and I'm not going to do it
again,
but I'm not going to beat myself to death so that I can't get up again.
And so you do what you can to forgive yourself.
You know,
it's a confusing time to live in in many ways because we have the birth control
pill now and that means reproduction has now become voluntary.
Well,
when's a good time to reproduce?
never,
because who would ever think about doing that?
It's so ridiculously irrational and complicated and the burden of responsibility
is so insanely high and you never secure enough to,
to have the proper place to bring children into the world.
And you have to get your career going and your,
and your intimate relationship.
And maybe you have some struggle doing that and one day you wake up and it's a
bit late.
It's like,
yeah,
well you're a product of your time.
And one of the prices that we're going to pay for having birth control for
having reliable contraception is that some people are going to make the wrong
decision with regards to having children.
And then you view yourself as a product of your time.
And that's a catastrophe,
you know,
because to be a product of your time is in some ways a catastrophe.
So,
but there's other things to do in life and,
and augering yourself into the ground with regret and,
and,
and self recrimination is not useful.
Right?
I mean,
you have to learn your lesson,
you have to take your lumps,
all of that,
but have some mercy.
You know?
That's,
it.